if they take Trump off the ballot
there 2024 is going to be wild let's
talk about what happens in 2024 if Trump
is removed from any state they'll try to
make that state award its electors to
the Democrat maybe they'll try and make
I doubted this but award to someone I
don't know libertarian or something it's
like well we're not going to give the
Democrats we're being fair but you need
to get 270 if you don't it goes to the
House of Representatives they cannot let
that happen
I have no idea what's gonna happen the
speculation is they'll take Trump's name
off the ballot in Michigan or
Pennsylvania or Georgia I think Georgia
is the key Target yeah they're trying to
use the 14th Amendment did you get them
on get them on uh charges of well
sedition of course so that they can use
the 14th Amendment to try to remove him
from certain States that's that's why
they want this to be a very very fast
trial because they they want to knock
Trump out before the primaries conclude
that's why I was saying when Trump came
out and said everybody should drop out
of the race he's got a point if they all
dropped out right now the Democrats
hands are tied if they remove his name
from the ballot pre-primary they say
look we didn't get rid of the
Republicans you have a choice you just
can't vote for the for the criminal if
everyone drops out and right now Trump
has confirmed the nominee the removal of
Donald Trump would be them saying the
Republican party has been excised from
the vote and then that's a shock to the
system I'm not saying I know what
happens after that but frogs boiling in
a pot is a bad scenario people being
shocked at the point of waking up is
preferable
the only way they can pull this off if
is if there was if the primaries are not
concluded and there was someone else
that if Trump were to be removed people
would would vote for
what do you think about like a Vivek RFK
ticket
no he don't like RFK I'm I'm like look
man RFK is better than a lot of the op
options yes you know what I mean and
it's kind of like
my I mean I I think of a trump Rama
Swami ticket would be like might the
best and I've talked to you about the
story I don't I'm not into Trump I mean
I don't dislike I don't I got issues
with them you know calling Rosie a fat
pig I feel like he alienated half the
world and like I need a uniter I need
someone that's gonna like help us move
forward I think Unity is cliche you know
I think that uh there's no really
there's really no such thing as unity
and I think it's like a very Kumbaya
concept and I don't think that we really
need to be focused on unity in this
country we are we are we are in a
political revolution right now and one
the party that's in control is literally
trying to put conservatives and Trump
supporters in jail so that they can die
in prison simply because of the person
they support or the fact that they
believe that the election was stolen
there's no room to play nice there's no
more there's no more talk about civility
no more talk about Unity we're in a war
to save our country and this is the
problem right this is why we're in the
mess today is because so many people and
this is no disrespect to you but so many
people in this country are focused on
civil ability and decorum and you know
let's go along to get along so many
think of it so many people on the right
are like that yeah that's right the
leftists are burning down cities the
ride is like that and that's why the
Republicans lose the country is called
the United States it's united we have
unity and that's the reason we function
as 50 states without it it'd be a civil
war so we need to no but we're in the
Civil War right now we don't have unity
and let me address that I don't believe
anyone can win on that platform let me
address that from the left
one of the issues with the Declaration
of Independence was that there were I
think it was what South Carolina and
Georgia would not sign on unless they
removed uh Thomas Jefferson's criticisms
of slavery so Unity doesn't always mean
the best things yeah I can understand
the argument among the founding fathers
they were like ah okay well we have no
choice I do believe that Quebec was was
it was a colony of the crown and they
did not want to join up so they were
like we desperately need other colonies
to agree with us thus let's just ignore
the slavery thing for now and I'm kind
of like wow that sucked that sucked but
I get the argument you know I'm not
going to sit here and criticize the
founding fathers for winning the
Revolutionary War just consider
sometimes this idea of unity means
unifying with people who are very very
bad and very very bad Hitler tried to
unify Europe I mean it was not the best
form of unification so right so right
now the challenge we I see in this
country is he didn't try to
extermination is not unification seizing
Paris was a step forward
you could make the r argument that
Hitler was doing horrifying awful things
he was conquering it to unify it like
the the simple academic term is
unification of Europe is what people
refer to and no one's ever saying like
that's not an argument to me it's in
agreement with Tim unification is not
always good I was not aware that they
called it unification I did not I was
not aware that the extermination of Jews
and Chip Seasons but what he was
notifications what Hitler was doing
invading other countries and stealing
territory trying to invade Russia was
conquer and and dominate yeah under one
umbrella to control everything and yes
he was a psychotic eugenicist
anti-semite racist and all of those
awful things but in in a simple sense
unification I think they call it
European unification or whatever yeah I
think it's fair to say that like
conquering like what outside of that my
point is this right now in the United
States we have states that allow for the
kidnapping of children to be castrated
and they are legally protected you have
States like California that are
Sanctuary States yeah that are
completely violent in the Constitution
so I'm sorry to say as much as I can
understand there is power in unity right
now what you have is not Unity you have
someone pinning you to the ground and
beating you in the face but I'm a bit of
a utilitarian if if California were
excised the communist Chinese party
would land destroyers
California we don't want to conquer it
then they'd they'd appeal to the Chinese
for help for Destroyer for for
battleships submarines nuclear
submarines like if we split up we lose
and I don't think we should split up I
think the federal government needs to be
purged of the corruption oh I agree with
talks fervently about it absolutely but
does Donald he he mentions that he's
gonna but he never plays out a plan I've
never seen a plan I will combine two
statements from the day Bill Mitchell
saying that Trump is the big guy and
DeSantis is the is the guy who executes
the vision well I think DeSantis says
that chip has sailed but Vivek is
running the campaign the Santa should
have run so let Trump be the big guy who
oversees the thing and then let Vivek be
the the the surgeon who goes in and
executes
Rhonda Santos doesn't execute Visions
the only things he's the only thing that
Ron DeSantis has executed is his
campaign for president okay that should
be a t-shirt
I'm sorry yeah he's too slow he's just
not adaptable he's not and also it's a
facade he's a Manchurian Candidate and
I'm just so sick and tired as a
Floridian as somebody who's actually you
know impacted by uh these these negative
policies as a result of him allowing for
Florida to literally be invaded I mean
he has allowed our state to be invaded
at the expense of people who are already
living there and he doesn't care he
doesn't care I'm gonna own this one
I feel personally slighted to the point
where I'm sick of the DeSantis campaign
yeah I'm sick of these people and when I
brought this up to Bill Mitchell and he
was a very nice guy after we wrapped the
show we were all hanging out having
sushi we played poker he got a full
house it was good fun even you know
Laura and him got along and where
cordial and everything was great but in
this debate I said I'm wondering why it
is that I'm not I'm not this crazy Die
Hard Trump or I'm not tweeting insults
at people I'm not attacking anybody but
when I have even the lightest criticism
of Rhonda Santos that's not even overt
criticism his actual campaign staff and
his and the staff of his uh his
governor's office insult me and attack
me and the immediate response was oh
yeah but you know Alex bruceowitz did
this and Laura Loomer did this and I'm
like okay stop I'm not them I don't care
I'm asking you why they why it is that
there's people like me or Mike cernovich
and several others who have said that
the DeSantis surrogates and campaign
staff have been vicious towards people
who should be allies
he didn't have an answer and he said oh
please I can't believe I'm hearing this
blah blah I'm like okay fine there's no
answer and this is all that we deserve
for the people that were for a long time
like a year ago me praising DeSantis
right and now I'm just being attacked
relentlessly I'm sorry I will own it I
am personally insulted personally
slighted and I am just sick of their
campaign and the campaign staff yeah so
you know what screw it on I mean
DeSantis is done he's number he he
already fell to number three in the
predictive that's because he's gonna be
number three at the end vivek's on an
upward Trend so it is Trump and Vivek is
who we should be talking about and Vivek
is smart enough to know he's not gonna
he's not gonna defeat Goliath here well
but this is what's so bad about Rhonda
Santos you know you just said it
everybody knows it he's done but the
Sinister aspect of the Rhonda Santos
campaign is that he knows that he has no
chance okay I call it the wrong disaster
campaign because it's absolutely
disastrous okay I call him Ron Decon
because he's an absolute con man okay
you just put his I mean the the fact
that he has de as his initials right uh
you could just you know call him
whatever you want but uh the fact is is
that Rhonda Santos is only existing in
this presidential race for the sake of
soaking up valuable GOP donor resources
that could otherwise be used for
election Integrity efforts or for
litigation to combat a weaponized
government and when you look at all
these candidates when you combine all
the resources collectively at the end of
this stupid primary when everybody
should just drop the hell out and
endorse Donald Trump and rally behind
him for the sake of our country and
getting reputation rep and getting
revenge rather and um and retribution
against these goddamn Communists okay
one billion to 1.5 billion dollars and
that's a lot of money that's a lot of
money I'm looking forward to it because
our ad revenue is going to say they're
taking they're taking that money and
it's essentially going to guarantee
Biden another four years if they don't
drop out and get behind Donald Trump
that's what this is about they know they
can't win let me ask you a question a
hypothetical I was thinking this in my
head
I don't I I don't know any realistic
scenario where Trump is forcefully
removed that makes someone feel good
about voting for someone else like if
you're a trump supporter and they lock
Trump up you're like no way I'm behind
Trump so there's got to be some kind of
scenario for me to ask this question so
I'll go with an absurd scenario for the
sake of argument let's say that there is
um a super you know let's let's just say
uh an evil globalist plants the the
Genesis device in the base of New York
City and the only one who can stop it is
Trump and Trump runs in and they're like
no Trump if you go in there you'll be
transported to another dimension and
you'll be completely wiped from
existence and he's like it's the only
thing that I can do to save all the
people of the world and then he disrupts
the device and he's gone Trump just
sacrifice he's gone there's no more
Trump he's not forced out there's no
possible scenario to vote for him would
you vote for Vivint
the only person that I'm voting for is
President Donald Trump but that's why I
asked in the most absurd way possible
Trump sacrifices himself to save
humanity and now he's gone forever
and the only Humanity's gonna crumble
because the only way that we're going
because she's not entertaining your
games pool she's not putting up with
your games
I don't like hypotheticals you know I'm
not really into all this like hopium
copy and that the Republican
party is trying to force feed voters
right amarilla some people say that I'm
negative right uh some people say that I
talk to I speak too badly about
Republicans but guess what I like to
call myself an equal opportunity hater
okay because I hate the Republican party
and I hate the Democrat Party I hate all
political parties actually and that's
why I like Donald Trump right because
he's a disrupter he's a sledgehammer to
the UNA party that has awakened and has
provided a voice to the Forgotten man
and forgotten woman of this country
who have been completely screwed over by
both political parties and that is the
reason why okay Donald Trump is being
attacked by the left and the right the
people that are doing the most damage
right now to Donald Trump aren't these
prosecutors and these these radical
these radical judges it's the
Republicans in office elected
Republicans that are staying silent I
mean where is Kevin McCarthy right our
Congress is on vacation right now when
they should actually be in Washington
D.C fighting against the weaponized
government and taking a stand because
the heist of the 2024 election is taking
place before our eyes right now and
Republicans are I'd like to say asleep
at the wheel but they're participating
I want to shift do you want to talk
about Trump's Sledgehammer strategy
because I I feel like if we're all on a
ship together the United States and the
Commander's like I'm going to destroy
this corruption in our system and just
start breaking the ship apart we all
drown and die like what is what Vision
does he offer other than I'm going to
end all the bad stuff like let me tell
me what you want to create so you say
we're on a ship and he's taking Hammer
to it let me let me give you a better
analogy we're on a ship and there's a
bunch of little uh Golems running around
ripping the cables out of the wall and
he's like I'm gonna put an end to this
and he gets a little net and starts
catching all the little goblins in a net
and and then he's chucking them into a
safe little boat where they'll be that's
what he told me he's gonna do in 2016.
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time